they're wanting to impose themselves
over Chelsea again
that's right Martin but I think when you
look at the two line of what we won't
get is a shortage of goals and expecting
plenty of entertainment out here today
here's the Chelsea liner Thibaut
Courtois dancing go John Terry plays
with Gary Cahill in central defense
Diego Costa is the lone striker today
this is then the Manchester United liner
having to hire starts in gold Chris
Smalling starts with erring bytes and
the back Paul Pogba plays alongside
Maren Fellaini in the middle of the park
I can't Ibrahim a which is the lone
striker today well this Wembley has its
own history now and I must say the
ground worthy of staging these very very
big occasions and being home of course
to England the national team I'm it's
it's a huge stadium busy I'll tell you
what the players would appreciate it's a
much better pitch than it was in the old
one much more like the Premier League
features
it's good movement they're getting
poured here Manchester United
timely challenge would be the plays
teammate through
but make a chance with this taco
the competition is
there's a backup gun well didn't we take
it well the suit thirdly finished look
at her phones as well
they feed that market a winner really
well hit really well directed we say
it's often perfect that one
truly unstoppable with Akita where the
first goal is one day
that's his game is there intercepting
Valencia
first touch was taught
Diego Costa
with forward play from them
for it that's a corner Chelsea
goalkeeper comes out with a punch and
it's a headache chance now
Ivanovitch
rather building steadily here working
away we've got it tackle in the balls
gone out now and it's going to be an
attacking move that's from Chelsea
Cesc fàbregas
to be as break handsome the goalkeeper
to make that kind of say
now Mickey Quran is Rooney
and struggling
that's the way to win the ball back
Chelsea on the attack
to say
exam to cut that bus
Diego Costa and the goalkeeper can take
charge now
let's cut out
I'm undersigned able to dwell on the
ball for very long here just working
away to try and find an opening
look sure
Diego Costa
well I don't know who the lad saw
they're passing the ball somebody in the
crowd maybe
Henrik Makita Rhea
impressive attacking play here from
Manchester United doing well to keep the
ball
shoots now for the pass
credit for the effort the intention but
the technique was poor
here's a chance to attack
final this
it's been knitter top gildo and I just
don't know which way it's gonna go
golde to show for their excellent
performance in a game where really we
expected it to be very tight yeah and I
didn't quite know what to expect coming
into it in terms of who was going to win
but the lead inside is there on there it
is level both sides have scored here's
out now Rooney
Matich it's a foul
now it's with Wayne Rooney moving
forward with some danger to the
opposition now they're here
promising build up until challenge
Lattin Ibrahimovic or it could have been
the go-ahead goal or what a chance to
get the noses in frontier maybe you
won't get too many better
the money at matok makes the challenge
here
now by
Ezrin eight
Delaney
quality on the ball
does greet the going well this lad
trying to find a way through here
groping away oh it's a known goal
well there is a goal it is an own goal
of nothing there's much doubt about that
Alan no none have told you and those
positions often and sometimes it does go
wrong
bad enough to be behind now but to do it
with an own-goal is particularly
annoying for the team and the player in
question
Chelsea attacking here
now they've got the chance to push
forward from this deep ish position
it comes to cross the ball deserve
perhaps a better response from his
teammates in the middle the defender got
there first though
you'll need to try and get the bull back
now
now it's with Wayne Rooney who's coming
forward with some danger Nikita
coming in and he's kept the ball out of
the penalty area with that block the
defender that's an easy interception the
pass wasn't really a very thoughtful one
that's coming in now it's a good piece
of defending to stop the supply into the
halfway through the FA Cup final and
it's a narrow deficit at the moment
plenty potential to turn it round in the
second half yeah I think all I've got to
do Martin is just to retain the belief
that they can get back into it because
they've had one or two chances in that
first half